hello hello and welcome to this video
wait for a day to my opponent so I got a
banker on the board he declines it with
native three okay so he's six not
something that I had on the board a lot
yeah I can take the pawn I can take up
on and it's not bad it's not bad it's
just I mean why don't usually gets the
pawn back and it is not particularly
interesting so this is an alternative to
be a little bit more fighting so I'm
going for it just taking is equal but
not very interesting here black tries to
fight against thirty five pawns the only
pawn weakness that white has but it is
something to play against typical play
this like this and now I can go not sure
about it ok furbish you have six it's
not clear that I want to do that but it
is a possible idea
hmm yep I probably have to stop this
okay so what's going on here Bishop to
f6 it seems i can still not play due to
the d6 weakness hmm i wonder if a bishop
a sex symbol hmm it cannot easily
support the bishop okay i can try it I
mean it doesn't really hurt to try you
should not underestimate that the d5
point is really weak inside is a problem
for what okay I can still not play
Bishop f6 somehow hmm but to see doing
your night I wonder if I should move the
rook can also do this oh nice got 95
maybe yeah like a look at 295 this could
be okay maybe not not such a big
beginning big deal I can go see for in
this position I wonder if it's an idea
c4 takes nine to five and take a for
certainly playable I wonder if I remove
the rook it's probably not good young
that sets take this opportunity to get
this activity on the road we are not
taking only for is a little bit risky as
sorry on d5 is a little bit risky I mean
the plan that I played us it's not like
terrible but it is a risky plan if you
grab the porn and you have very good
equalizer
chances i think it's just completely and
it reduces some pieces on the board
considerably so i did not want to trade
that much ok so here Knight b6 probably
and then the airport position looks
entirely unclear to me Jim I don't think
I'm goes here probably around equal 90
form hmm not a bad idea so to get rid
hear of this pressure
and that if I can take probably why did
I move the night then okay for the
airport okay which can be stopped quite
comfortably still oh you know it takes
this time going on that opened fire huh
yeah yeah I seem okay and it's um need
some air some lift anyway probably live
at the a pawn I mean yester like lad
before I take a play for I mean this is
still somewhat dangerous and ce4 is also
under fire I'm not easy i'm not easier
this position maybe he can check on the
six father know for the back wang and
two pieces hanging no that doesn't work
well I wonder if he has some tactic yet
it's possible my pieces look a bit
strange didn't find any particularly
scary tactic yeah but I didn't see this
sorry i was thinking this does not work
and then I then the ape on a three-year
up takes a two and touchdown
I mean I'm just fully promoting he
cannot even give up a minor piece there
can only give up the rook
yeah I know slightly risky I think this
pollution was certainly I'm pretty
certain there was something for him
quite resigned okay so let's have a look
at them and see you have the reliable
theoretical continuation is to take with
the night as sorry to take with the
bishop forgot about that first this
morning this can be three and here um
how does that work actually I don't
remember this this castles Bishop e7
something like this yeah and then the c5
porn is usually falling I think what the
engine is giving is actually correct the
correct line we should be five castles
this this and yeah this is the mine yeah
this is this is equal I think oops not
this this this and then route be 65 it
should be a roughly equal okay the sixes
is the risky move and yeah probably this
is wrong and 98 a spare I hear the
engine for instance actually for we
should have six like that so that g6 is
not hanging down but here it looks like
why it should be better rookie woman
hmm txtx this one gets to buy this
better maybe here yeah i'm just hanging
on it's always wet night b3 how
embarrassing ok so we have should have
gone here yeah I'm in trouble very much
in trouble so Quinn screen see to take
this and 95 coming yeah yeah I'm in
trouble and ok here not be three was
possible which is still not like an easy
win actually but I should I should of
course at least see the move the
computer is not super convinced here
probably because mine yeah my whole
coordination sucks the engine wants to
play like this Wow
not sure that black & windus I've
doubted and now it's entirely unclear h6
I could've played and now this user's
right now I'd seen this like two or
three moves ago I mean covering this and
the a porn is dangerous so it was a
little bit lucky but okay it's probably
assume it comes with the risks a few
take more risks you you need some luck
to win but you do actually do win
sometimes ok guys thanks for watching